[Music]
it's beautiful amigo perfect but useless
I have something for you Diego give me
your hands
papa
no the grenade is simple it has four
basic parts the shell which contains the
explosive defuse the handle and of
course the pin what are you doing
breathe the pin simply off the handle in
place it is only when you let go that
this grenade goes boom follow me
now I am El Presidente which means that
someday you will be our president and
our people they do not know how to be
happy they are torn apart by opinions
noise indecision strangled by their own
freedoms and even if you have love in
your heart even if you want what's best
for them if you only want to save them
from themselves
they will hate you do everything you say
do believe we'll be wrong
[Music]
they will ask her you screams
call you evil
and monster
and give you
this
so you tell me are you giving
are you a monster
because our country is like this grenade
except it has two basic parts our people
and new and you must clutch them nice
and died or we've all
[Music]
they understand now
it
you